the guitar that you broke in that scene
was an actual nice Martin guitar it was
the one that Jennifer was learning to
play on she was getting good on on on
and comfortable we'd be there at like
2:00 in the morning and I'd walked by
Jennifer's uh Bungalow and going on man
wow home girl still here I didn't know
that there was just one guitar that she
felt that way about and then on that day
Quenton just said um just go until I
till I say stop I said so if you don't
say stop I smash the guitar he said yep
great Quenton knew exactly what he was
doing he wanted to see the look on face
when she smashed that old antique Martin
guitar and I took the thing and I said
the line music time's over smash the
guitar and she just and then we cut and
she was she just smashed the real guitar
and I'm thinking real guitar they're all
real so then I found out later that that
guitar was the real Gibson I guess and
we are not lending any more guitars to
movies